موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم كشف برنامج الجزيره
التحقيقين خفي اعظم عن وثائق ومراسلات
سريه للفريق الروسي الذي اعتقل في العاصمه
الليبيه طرابلس عام 2019 وحصل برنامج ما
خفي اعظم على نسخه من ارشيف سري روسي في
ليبيا وعلى مراسلات توثق تفاصيل
الاجتماعات السريه بين الروس وسيف الاسلام
القذافي لاعادته للمشهد السياسي ويكشف
البرنامج عن وثائق ومستندات لسيف الاسلام
القذافي تتضمن ادعاءات عن تلقي ماكرون
اموالا الليبيه وحوالات ماليه لشخصيات
امريكيه واخرى اوكرانيه نافذه
اكدت هيئه اركان الجيش الاوكراني ان
القوات الروسيه تواصل محاولاتها للتقدم
نحو مدينه باخموت ومحاصرتها رغم الخسائر
التي تتكبدها وقال موقع ريبار العسكري
الروسي ان قوات فاجنار تواصل الضغط على
القوات الاوكرانيه في الجهتين الشماليه
والجنوبيه وان اعنف المعارك تدور داخل
المنطقه الصناعيه
قله المتحدث باسم ان قرار بولندا
وسلوفاكيا تزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات تسعه
وعشرين مثال على زياده عدد من دول الناتو
الخراطه في الصراع وحذرت من تداعيات ذلك
وكان رئيس الوزراء سلوفاكي ادوارد هيجر
اعلن ان بلاده وافقت على ارسال ثلاثه عشره
مقاتله من طراز 29 الى اوكرانيا
اصدرت المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مذكرتي
توقيف في حق الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
ومفوضه حقوق الطفل في الرئاسه الروسيه
مرايا بيلوفا وقال الرئيس المحكمه بيوت
ان المذكرتين اصدرتا لمسؤولياتهما التي في
الترحيل غير القانوني للاطفال في اوكرانيا
اعتبر المتحدث باسم الكرملين
مستفزا وغير مقبول وقال ان موسكو لا تعترف
بالمحكمه ولا قيمه لقراراتها قانونيا حسب
قوله
تجددت المظاهرات في باريس ومدن فرنسيه
اخرى احتجاجا على تصديق الرئيس مانويل
ماكرون على قانون التقاعد دون تصويت
برلماني وقد اعتقلت الشرطه اكثر من 300
شخص بين مداعات تنسيقيه النقابات الى
اضراب العام ومظاهرات الخميس المقبل وفيما
تتحرك المعارضه لسحب الثقه من الحكومه
كشفت مصادر ان الرئيس الفرنسي لوح بحل
البرلمان اثناء اخر مناقشات بشان قانون
التقاعد
منحت محكمه لاهور العليا رئيس الحكومه
الباكستانيه السابق عمران خان حمايه
قضائيه لمده اسبوع تحول دون اعتقاله في 9
محاضر فتحت في مراكز شرطه مؤخرا بتهم
مختلفه وكانت محكمه اسلام اباد العليا قد
طالبت الشرطه بعدم اعتقال خان اثناء تنقله
من لاهور الى العاصمه اسلام اباد المقرر
اليوم السبت للمثول امام محكمه ابتدائيه
[موسيقى]
كتاب الموجز الى اللقاء